[Aplausos]
[Música]
bom só por causa disso é quem já ouviu
falar em blog chan
quem conhece bloco em ficar com o braço
levantado por que eu posso fazer uma
pergunta é bom mas então o título
realmente está interessante porque tem
muito a ver com isso eu acho que não vou
perguntar a vocês o que é um tsunami
eu creio que vocês já ouviram na
televisão já ouviram falar dessas ondas
gigantescas que chegam a provocados por
terremotos
como recentemente alguns poucos anos
atrás tivemos no nordeste do japão
o efeito devastador é muito grande
as fotos mostram isso os vídeos que
vocês viram na televisão mostram
claramente mas reparem o que é um
tsunami é uma onda de choque provocada
por um terremoto
esse terremoto estiver 1 600 e 700
quilômetros do litoral
como é que nós reconhecemos um tsunami
em alto mar
não reconhecemos só através de sensores
que nós conseguimos identificar que um
tsunami está passando por ali que as
ondas basicamente ontem 10 20
centímetros
é exatamente isso que blot prontinho
hoje é um tsunami autónoma
talvez a gente tem ouvido falar que o
terremoto aconteceu sismógrafo registrou
mas não sabemos quando ele vai chegar
mas sabemos sim que ele pode e
potencialmente vai trazer significativas
mudanças nos negócios nas nossas
atividades e eventualmente tirar algumas
empresas às suas atividades pode acabar
com os setores inteiros mas para
entendermos um pouquinho do porquê essa
tecnologia digital com blocos quem está
chegando chegando neste momento vamos
dar um passo para trás
não muito longe quando saí aqui do
círculo vermelho mas vemos como nós
estamos numa sociedade cada vez mais
digitalizada
a tecnologia digital faz parte do nosso
dia a dia na hora que nós acordamos até
a hora que nós vamos dormir nós estamos
interagindo
alguma tecnologia digital talvez a gente
perceba
talvez a gente não perceba mas por que
tanta tecnologia digital está
acontecendo hoje
basicamente a tecnologia digital evolui
exponencialmente exponencialmente
significa que cada passo evolutivo é o
dobro do anterior e se muito diferente
do nosso conceito básico e nós pensamos
linearmente
mas quando eu peço minha mente eu dou 30
passos cada um passo metro
andei 30 metros exponencialmente o
primeiro passo é um segundo e 248 30º
passos são 26 voltas à terra
um exemplo claro está em 30 anos atrás
um supercomputador custava 10 milhões de
dólares apenas 27 máquinas foram
construídas ocupa três salas dessa
hoje a capacidade computacional de
supercomputador está no nosso bolso
osmar ponto ao longo desses anos nós
fomos vendo algumas marcas
significativas da evolução da tecnologia
a invenção do próprio computador o
microcomputador e operacional com o
piloto eu pensei em 1981 que permitiu
que as pessoas tivessem acesso à
computação a internet world wide web
a própria www que a principal aplicação
da internet surgiu em 1991 e mais
recentemente um ano que mudou a nossa
vida 2007 2007 saiu o iphone e aí surgir
outros marrons não repõe o que o
smartphone fez pra gente se tornou parte
do nosso corpo humano
a gente não sai de casa assim ele está
preso a gente não consegue absolutamente
viver sem ele
ele é o nosso despertador gente vê
notícias fofocas do facebook manda
mensagem de filmes ou ouvir músicas
fazemos uma compra de uma passagem
fazemos transferência eletrônica de
dinheiro ou seja praticamente tudo o que
nós podemos fazer de alguma forma o
smartphone nos permite fazê lo então uma
folha é uma marca significativa nesse
avanço da disseminação da tecnologia na
digamos na pulverização da tecnologia
criando realmente
a sociedade conectada eu diria até
hiperconectada isso significa mudanças
significativas na maneira como nós
acessamos e consumimos informação nós
produzimos informação estavam tirando
fotos aqui colocado no facebook no
twitter
a maneira como se trabalha será que o
trabalho eu preciso me deslocar para
algum local de trabalho onde estou e nós
temos uma geração digital uma geração
que já nasceu com o mundo da internet há
20 anos atrás ela surgiu
quem nasceu de 20 anos pra cá já nasceu
como pano de fundo a internet e quem tem
menos idade dez anos já com o iphone
como pano de fundo
diferente de mim que vim do mundo
analógico e tive que me naturalizar no
mundo digital
mas os nativos digitais tem uma maneira
de pensar diferente e é isso que nós
temos que nos cuidar o que nós temos que
nos posicionar realmente não pensemos
mais do mundo analógico para o digital
mas pensemos como os nativos digitais
vamos buscar tecnologias realmente
digitais e o blog quem tem essa
característica
não vamos entrar em detalhes do que é o
bloco que em termos técnicos
vocês não precisam saber por exemplo
como é feita complexa triangulação de
localização de um objeto como o gps
funciona sem uso e se você não precisa
saber como funciona a internet em
detalhes como os pacotes de dados
enviados serão usa o google então não
precisamos saber em detalhes do que o
bloco é basicamente um livro razão
imagem uma planilha onde cada registro
tem lá de de para onde o valor é
criptografada e armazenada e esgares
milhares e milhares de computadores
basicamente isso
um livro razão distribuído vamos apenas
ficar com esse conceito mas vamos ver o
que nós podemos fazer com ele
como nós temos o potencial do que fazer
com eles o que fazia com o google o
google vocês sabem vocês não precisam
mais a buscar mais nada numa leitura
vocês podem acessar um buscador a mesma
coisa não vão olhar no no blog
vamos pensar que nós podemos fazer com o
bloco tem a primeira coisa que se
imagina
e que realmente muito de vocês devem
estar pensando próprio quem é a moeda
criptográfica como o bitcoin não bitcoin
é uma aplicação do bloco
na verdade o bitcoin surgiu tornou se
bastante popular agora tem um valor
bastante alto de mercado mas a
tecnologia está por trás é o bloco g e
muitas vezes a gente confunde a bitkom
em bloco e não simplesmente medicou é
uma aplicação mas é importante nós
entendemos que o bitcoin está
funcionando existe porque ele está
provando que a tecnologia funciona e
está provando uma coisa muito importante
quando você negocia moedas seja uma
crypton moeda
você está colocando nessa operação
confiança confiança significa que eu
estou transferindo uma montante de
dinheiro para alguém o transfer vendendo
alguma coisa para alguém e esse alguém é
fulano tem uma determinada a
identificação eo montante está aqui eu
sei que ele vai receber ele sabe que
estou enviando para ele a confiança a
minimização do risco
então se eu consigo ter confiança usando
blocos chen na transação de moedas seja
o bitcoin talvez eu possa um pouco mais
à frente e nesse e mais à frente os
bancos foram os primeiros a se
preocuparem com isso espera aí
se existe uma boa crypton moeda existe a
possibilidade das pessoas fazerem essa
transação de confiança mútua
isto é o meu papel no papel o banco é
exatamente isso eu não conheço cada um
de vocês mas eu faço uma transação vendo
alguma coisa e vocês eu sei que vocês
vão pagar porque tem um meio ali
intermediário um agente intermediário
chamado banco que garante isso
ele tira de um tiro do outro faz esse
controle
mas se eu não precisar mais do banco eu
como banco fico preocupado ou parte
espera aí eu vou perder relevância e se
o risco mas por outro lado eu não quero
sair do negócio eu quero continuar como
um negócio lucrativo
será que não têm uma oportunidade daí
que os bancos começaram a ver que existe
sim possibilidade de explorar a
tecnologia
legal ótimo os bancos saíram na frente e
com certeza quem ouviu falar do bloco
tinha deve ter associado o blog chan
a atividade financeira nós vamos muito
além dos bancos
se nós estamos fazendo uma transação que
garante confiança seja um dinheiro isso
pode ser o registro propriedade
sim podemos pensar por exemplo no
registro de imóveis
olha quanta dificuldade hoje temos para
fazer uma transação imobiliária
você passa por cartório registro de
imóveis o vendedor eo comprador mas se
eu puder fazer isso diretamente sem
intermediários eliminando toda toda essa
e se arrastando toda essa essa
dificuldade e seria muito mais eficiente
sim então podemos falar em registo de
imóveis
se falamos em resistir móveis certidão
de casamento certidão de casamento
registro acadêmico então eu consigo
trabalhar com qualquer tipo de documento
sem intermediários no começo a ter um
processo desintermediação eu tenho a
garantia que aquela informação ela é
perpétua
eu não consigo apagar um registo que eu
gravo no bloco j
eu consigo atualizá lo mas aquele está
lá então consigo sempre voltar ao
passado e saber por exemplo que fui
louca casa na europa mas ele está casado
aqui não tem mais como omitir isso como
apagar essa informação
ok nós falamos então em registro de
documentos nós podemos um pouco mais à
frente virar origem de determinado
produto
não sei se vocês viram esse filme
diamante de sangue que ele retrata um
pouco romance ado mas retrata a situação
em determinadas situações determinados
locais da áfrica onde a guerrilha onde a
criminalidade muito elevada na extração
de diamantes e uma preocupação muito
grande com a sociedade
na origem do diamante que aquele
diamante não seja um diamante de sangue
mas ser um diamante extraído uma área
correta numa área antes de com direitos
legais
nós podemos fazer o rastreamento de um
objeto como um diamante desde a sua
extração até a sua venda uma obra de
arte
o direito autoral eu consigo saber que
aquele artista pintou aquele quadro é um
quadro falsificado
essas iniciativas já estão existindo já
são operações que estão funcionando não
em um larga escala mas já estão
funcionando mostram-se fact podemos um
pouco mais à frente a própria música a
música digital nada mais é que um
conjunto de bits e se nesse conjunto de
bits eu coloco um pedaço de código de
software
nada mais do que um pequeno programa num
contexto chamado de contrato inteligente
smaato contrato significa que na
execução daquela música aquele programa
pode ser executado e eu consigo
transferir da minha carteira virtual por
exemplo eu sou pessoa que está ouvindo a
música para a carteira virtual do
compositor diretamente iniciativas já
estão acontecendo
o spotify já está fazendo experiências
nesse sentido e diversas outras tops
entram nesse processo também então
consigo ter claramente aí a
desintermediação de um processo de
registro autoral e saber se alguém está
ouvindo a música indevidamente e naquela
festa tem alguém ouvindo não está
pagando executou a música eu tenho o
débito automático
podemos um pouco mais à frente nós
estamos acostumados por exemplo a usar
modos de transporte como um gol
o cap fai 99 que são essas plataformas
plataformas bastante criativas mas no
fundo são agregadoras entre um conjunto
de pessoas que quer oferecer um serviço
e conjunto de pessoas que querem
utilizar aquele serviço
mas será que eu preciso ter essa
plataforma no meio
será que não poderia diretamente fazer
uma ligação entre quem quer oferecer o
serviço e quem quer usar o serviço
sim é possível o arcade é um exemplo já
está nos estados unidos e provavelmente
deve começar a operação experimental no
brasil agora em dezembro
mas eu não preciso de um interno
a eólica que interessante um bairro
recente e já tem alguém ameaçam da
própria existência de algo que surgiu há
muito pouco tempo
reparem como o bloco tem um potencial de
opção muito grande podemos um pouco mais
à frente sim por que não pensar em novos
negócios
nós estamos falando cada vez mais em
tecnologia de energia renovável painéis
solares
nós estamos falando em veículos
elétricos a motos montadoras já definiu
como 2025 2027 a o terno de fabricação
dos seus veículos a combustão alguns
países como por exemplo a alemanha já
declararam oficialmente que em 2040
sairá de circulação um último veículo
ecu a movido a combustão
então a era do petróleo vai acabar assim
não por falta de petróleo como nós
imaginar nós por falta de demanda
então com veículos elétricos eu tenho
uma necessidade carregal ok vou
recarregar a bateria dele onde eu posso
fazer
a e pontos de recarga mas se eu tenho
painéis solares na minha casa todo
gerando energia para mim
leve um excedente que eu posso fazer com
excedente porque não vendeu
jogando na rede elétrica essa
experiência já acontece na alemanha
vocês estão vendo aí onde tem os pontos
de recarga em uma determinada cidade
você chega com o carro começa ali a
carregar sua bateria e através do blog
chin você faz o pagamento diretamente ao
dono da casa
isso muda completamente o nosso modo de
pensar o que é o sistema elétrico
portanto nós começamos a ver que o blog
tem um potencial de decepção muito
grande
vimos em termos de sistema financeiro
nós estamos falando dos documentos nós
estamos falando em energia elétrica
nós podemos falar na área de política
como por exemplo o projeto de lei
a nossa constituição em 88 permite que
nós cidadãos consigamos a levar um
projeto de lei para o para ser discutido
e eventualmente aprovado na câmara
mas para isso você tem que checar as
assinaturas
no caso do ficha limpa foi um exemplo
muito interessante
o ficha limpa só foi pra frente porque
um deputado assumiu adotou esse projeto
senão aconteceria ninguém conseguiria
fiscalizar milhão de assinaturas é
impossível um blog que você tem a
garantia que aquela informação é daquela
pessoa
então isso vai criar uma cidadania muito
mais forte o ativismo político muito
mais forte que nós estamos falando nisso
em ativismo político através de nós
pessoas nós cidadãos porque não a nossa
própria identidade seja identidade única
de quem é você com todos os seus dados
como até um passaporte e podemos pensar
num passaporte global
já estamos vendo isso acontecendo a
estônia por exemplo seus passaportes
seus sua carteira de identidade são
blocos chen e já existe uma tentativa de
uma república global em um blog onde
você tem um passaporte que seria
totalmente sem fronteiras se experimenta
só e sim com certeza nós estamos numa
fase ainda muito incipiente
nós estamos na infância do potencial do
bloco
sabemos que ele tem um potencial de
discussão muito grande é aquela onda que
nós vimos no início mas ele está em alto
mar
nós temos ainda muito claramente quando
ele vai chegar e com que o impacto ele
vai chegar à visão de futuro nada mais é
que uma visão minha estimativa de
probabilidades
mas com certeza o bloco quem vai chegar
e eu acredito que é importante que vocês
tenham claramente nos seus sensores uma
cozinha já piscando olha o bloco gente
está chegando
lope chantel impacto significativo e
potencial muito grande
eu tenho que me preparar para isso tem
que estudar tem que ler eu tenho que
começar a entender quais são as
consequências que isso poderá acarretar
para o que eu estou fazendo e para
eventualmente o negócio onde esteja
operando a desintermediação com certeza
é um fenômeno que vai acontecer com
muita
intensidade pensa exponencialmente não é
um metro um metro métodos e 248 16 e
assim por diante
não imagine que alcançar
exponencialmente essa minha restrição é
só a experimentações vão levar muito
tempo não essas coisas vão acontecer
muito mais rápido que nós imaginamos
portanto obrigado
[Aplausos]